if you knew these stats say like in high
school there was a class that taught you
about um
just a
womanhood and what actually happened
stats and all this stuff would you have
dated more intentionally when you were
younger
versus what you did
definitely
i think we should have a class
in high school
how to date men and men how to date
women
and how to value yourself and what you
look what are you looking for and who
you are i think that's so important
but um yeah in high school or even at
school i think they should have teach a
lot of things to prepare us for life
not just when it comes to dating or
relationships
but yeah definitely and can i just add
yeah a class would be all good and well
but
you could have that class be dating
intentionally and still meet a
non-starter it just i guess gives you a
i don't know more of a growth mindset as
opposed to a fixed one when it comes to
a relationship because through my 20s i
dated intentionally i was just
unfortunate to me you know did you did
you involve did you involve your dad
um
so on that subject for some families and
households
your dad being involved is not your
choice in my upbringing my dad being
involved or not being involved
had nothing to do with him it was more
sorry nothing to do with me it was an
issue between
him and my mom my dad wasn't around
maybe having my dad around yeah would
have definitely maybe impacted different
decisions that i've gained
but not everybody has that luxury so
yeah
well that's that's like um i think we as
women would do a lot better if we had
our dad's input more and more
because i started um after the last
relationship i got out of my dad like
warned me a little bit about it and i
didn't listen and i like literally now
guys i go on dates with or whatever i
tell my dad about them he gets so
irritated because he's like i have
better things to do but his advice has
actually been like
really helpful
because he can't like even if you're
just describing the guy to your dad like
or maybe it's not your dad but like
another male figure like i think men can
see through other men's like yeah yeah
better than you yeah
yeah because a guy will whisper sweet
nothing's into our ear but like the dad
will be like did he do this did he do
that did he do any of that he doesn't
like you like yeah i mean unfortunately
for me
i didn't have
that option yeah um growing into an
adult i guess i've i've been really
blessed with some good male friends that
can kind of give me their
their opinions let's say um
but in reflection
you know if my dad had have been
the type of man that
had those characteristics and traits to
be able to
tell me what to do and what not to do
then you know who knows where i would be
but you know it's just circumstance
unfortunately there's not
[Laughter]
so yeah i think as women we we kind of
have the tendency of daydream and
romanticize things over about like
relationships and men
and
i think we've had like a
a male figure present in our life our
father i didn't as well
uh maybe my outcome in men it would be
better yeah at least i did a good a good
choice my ex of seven years i'm glad
and i'm gonna i respectful as well but
my dad personally he
shouldn't be as
good a risky soul shouldn't be a
spokesperson for anyone to be completely
honest
his
relationship with my mom i was very
young with
um certain things that went on however
as an adult i've tried to avoid
men like him but then come straight into
contact
with men like him and because i didn't
know how to
i don't know like emotionally deal with
it you know you're just in a vicious
cycle of
[ __ ]
they say you're dead
so you know what this makes me think of
like how important it is for us to pick
good men to raise our kids
because if we
yeah like and um because like your mom
picking the wrong guy had so many
ramifications for you definitely and you
know it probably wasn't intentional
maybe she didn't have like a dad either
i don't know
it's funny that you say that yeah my
granddad he passed away
when my mum was really young so she
didn't have that
that male figure and then my nan god
bless her she
the sacrifices that you make for your
children she worked a lot so there
wasn't don't have the male presence and
with the greatest respect
not that much of a female motherly
presence because you know your mom's
doing the best that she can to try and
provide for you but
i don't know the hand i was dealt what
can i say yeah well because it becomes
how's your mom supposed to teach you how
to find a guy exactly and would you
believe her if like if she couldn't pick
a good guy yeah yeah if only if i've
gotten older that i'm more understanding
to those elements but when you're young
the the mind's a crazy thing where your
mind can go and the things that you feel
you deserve and the hands that you've
done it's just i don't know as an adult
now i can understand exactly where she's
coming from but let's say what five six
years ago it's just kind of like
where is me pity party for one yeah no
and it's um but it almost like
at least now we know you know we can try
to make better decisions in the future
but it's better than like lying to women
and saying
no we make great choices on our own
because i i don't and i've had a lot
better results since i've involved my
dad and i wish i did it sooner i think
it would have avoided me a lot of like
heartbreak to be honest yeah
so i think everything comes down to
childhood how we've been raised and then
you know if we don't stop the
outcome um how you say um cycle
yeah like the
[Music]
it's a cycle yeah you have to break the
cycle and you have to learn from your
past i that's what i look back because
um i was actually once um pregnant and i
did an abortion and because it was
because i didn't see my partner it would
be a great father to have that kid
because i know me growing up without a
father and knowing who is my father who
was a nominizer
my mom she raised me by herself
even though she was
not in a great
uh i mean financially
you know um
she did raise me very well and i
appreciate that
um but the thing is i look back and i'm
like
this would be my
greatest example to look in the future
to s that would inspire me and see
what's the best guy out there to be the
dad of my kids
and when i got pregnant and i did
abortion it was because of that it got
me to think
not just because of my career i was that
impact i mean that was
come to it as well but it was because as
well i didn't see him as the perfect
father and husband for myself and for my
kids i heard a man say once that if you
if you cannot see yourself having a
child with whoever you're dating whoever
you're talking to
you have you should not be with him yeah
break up with him and
don't talk to them and i was like
that is so
true
because so many women
romanticize and fantasize and see this
person that they're with but they don't
realize that if i'm engaging in sex with
this person there's a possibility that
we could have a child together and if
that's something that i do not see with
that person i should not be with them
even if it's rainbows and butterflies in
every other situation
if you cannot
see yourself taking care of a child with
that person you should not be with them
michael jackson said it the best
if you um oh
how does the lyrics go um
if you can't have a baby then if you
can't feed your baby yeah yeah if you
can't feed your baby then don't have a
baby like if you cannot see yourself
with that person no you should not be
with him
i don't know that's easier said than
done though because sometimes when
you're in the midst of these
relationship it's just
the fine line between reality and the
perception of
i mean i'm talking from experience but
it's just like i mean it's it's easier
said than done but then we have to
accept the consequences yeah complain
about the hand we're down yeah so like
you you you said you're in your 30s yep
and you're single because you made those
choices most definitely yeah and you
know i don't regret those choices
however they're also those elements
some choices i don't i don't regret
because
it's i would take back every shitty
relationship if i could because i don't
know
obviously it's not
you learned a lot as well i definitely
learned a lot yeah just you are more
aware being accountable and just
self-healing there's certain
things that i had to experience to just
be a bit more vulnerable and
understanding and and
calm so yeah maybe i would
take a different path with certain
things but it's just it's not a regret
everything that happened
to me happened the way it was supposed
to happen